tonight on Brian Ross investigators
class of 2013
Harvard University under fire from a
Nigerian born student from the class of
2013 who seemed like a future superstar
I am honored to speak to you today but
the morning of his graduation double R
Eason okie was told he would not be
receiving his degree allegations of
sexual misconduct brought by three
former girlfriends it's unthinkable what
happened to him now he's suing Harvard
in an explosive case in the meet to era
that raises questions of sex race and
due process on America's college
campuses let me ask you directly did you
rape these women did not know plus more
mystery in the air
what are who is flying high over the
night skies of Colorado and Nebraska
scaring local residents the FBI and the
FAA are said to be investigating they
appear as little twinkling lights
sometimes there's just one but in other
cases we've seen clusters of six or more
and are shut up for the woman who runs a
small nonprofit journalism outlet in
Memphis who exposed how one of the
city's big hospitals was going after
poor people who could not pay their
bills the result thousands of people at
their deaths wiped away from the law and
crime Network studio in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investing
good evening and welcome tonight we
begin with an explosive case surrounding
Harvard University and a young man who
was once one of its star students now
suing Harvard claiming he was a victim
of overzealous school officials who
sought to crack down on sexual
misconduct on campus at Harvard
University the graduation ceremonies
each year are a showcase of American
successful class of 2013 those who have
already made it like 2013 graduation
speaker Oprah Winfrey I thank you for
allowing me to be a part of the
conclusion of this chapter of your lives
and those who seemed destined to make it
Donna Lauria sanuki in 2013 the class
chose as its class day orator a Nigerian
born young man who grew up in a rough
neighborhood in Houston
Dublin R Eason Oke sophomore year my
cousin was shot and killed she was 22
when I was 16 I got shot accidentally by
a friend I try left the hospital that
night after watching my mom cry my
friends won't cry my other friends wanna
cry you know mom's I looked down I
noticed two bullet holes in my shirt
these holes remind me that eventually
isn't promised at Harvard so no key
worked on the school paper the Crimson
the famed humor magazine the Lampoon and
he was president of the Harvard black
men's forum here introducing special
speaker Van Jones like mr. Jones really
exemplifies our core principles of
brotherhood manhood and fidelity and
we're really excited welcome him today
thank you but as demo Lauriston oki
joined his classmates to walk down the
aisle and receive his diploma that day
in May of 2013 with his proud mother and
looking on he had just that morning been
given some devastating news about his
degree pulled aside by my president Dean
she put me aside and said you know mine
wouldn't be in my envelope because of
you know there was disciplinary you know
situation he could walk with his
classmates but the envelope he was to be
handed would be empty there would be no
diploma inside and now six and a half
years later Harvard still has not given
him his degree think about it somebody
goes to a school and for four years
studies and completes all the
requirements and then finds out that
they are not going to get a degree it's
unthinkable what happened to him
according to a lawsuits enoki has now
filed against harvard the school told
him just days before the graduation that
two women he had dated or room with had
accused him of sexual misconduct a third
woman he also knew filed a similar
complaint in the days after the
graduation and these were women with
whom you had long term relationships
yeah school there were people I've been
friends with for years and we you know
we had you know become instrument at
some point over the course of that and
one of them was you know so when I known
for you know a while in his lawsuit so
no key says the women were pressured by
Harvard to file their formal complaints
let me ask you directly did you rape
these women did not no nothing like that
from your point and I mean if I did I
mean if I were I mean no first of all no
I didn't like categorically but also if
I were you know as a black man in
Cambridge Massachusetts
if I were raping women left and right on
campus I probably wouldn't have been
chosen to speak yet as a Harvard or
ready to represent my client's chosen by
my classmates to speak as part of
graduation so no he says Harvard at
first told him they would take a few
weeks to further investigate the
allegations a process that dragged on
secretly for almost a year until the
decision was made permanent no degree of
there was no real clarity on you know
kind of what was going on a process that
his lawyers Christina super and Susan
stone of the Cleveland law firm Coleman
Jackson and Kravitz say is all too
common with such cases on college
campuses every student regardless of sex
should have the right to come forward
and report claims of sexual violence the
issue in this case is what should the
process be and what was the process here
that you most objective we must object
to the fact that Dahmer
he was in essence shut out of the
process and this is a 21 year old man at
the time with no attorney
doesn't even know the identities of the
witnesses against him no ability to
question the evidence against him and
really had to on his own work his way
through an entirely Byzantine and
convoluted process in fact in 2014
28 Harvard law professors wrote in The
Boston Globe that the university's
process for handling such cases lacked
the most basic elements of fairness and
due process are overwhelmingly stacked
against the accused and are in no way
required by title 9 law or regulation a
reference to the federal guidelines on
dealing with such cases so sanuki kept
his secret that he had not received a
degree from his family and from his new
employer in New York
Goldman Sachs where he had landed a
highly coveted position in finance they
found out from you know anonymously from
my case one called or something Sosa no
key had to leave his job at Goldman
Sachs his admission to Harvard Business
School was withdrawn and another
high-paying job offer in finance was
rescinded you're about to graduate you
know May 2013 and at the last second you
know your degree is you know everything
you've kind of worked for for your whole
life is just kind of you know picking
you instead so no key went to Hollywood
using his Harvard Lampoon connections to
land a job as a writer on the ABC sitcom
blackish today we're joined by Donna
Larry sanuki talented writer on the
award-winning show blackish where he
received notice as an up-and-coming
writer
who overcame adversity to go to Harvard
and you did we have to say for the
audience make it to Harvard so he didn't
disappoint your parents when it came to
that
so no keys life took on a dire turn when
he was indicted and pleaded guilty to a
charge of insider trading providing
stock tips to a professional football
player he had befriended something he
claims he did to raise enough money to
hire lawyers to sue Harvard I felt very
like a very hopeless situation and I was
focused on trying to get you know this
80,000 a hundred thousand or however
much you know these these lawyers you
think it's directly related but you
could you've made a bad decision right
yeah yeah I take you know it was very
very bad decision well didn't you make
that you made bad decisions when you're
under a lot of yeah no I mean that
wouldn't have happened you know one
thing wouldn't have happened without the
other I take responsibility very very
stupid it's not a good idea at all but
with all that behind him so no key is
now focused on his lawsuit against
Harford eager to get his degree and to
challenge the process that his lawsuit
says was weighted against him the
reality is Brian dumb Larry never had a
fighting chance to defend himself
whatsoever he was involved in a process
that was essentially what some call a
Star Chamber so he didn't even have an
opportunity to hear what was being said
about him to know whether his his side
of the story was being accurately
represented to the panel Anson Okies
lawsuit also claims that race played a
factor because the ad board did not
contain a black male voice back when da
malari went through the process there
was not a single African Amahle male on
the ad board which is the board that
decided that he should be sanctioned for
the allegations that were lodged against
him
Sanofi says he wants Harvard to finally
award him the degree he earned with a
three point six five grade point average
and restored the reputation he once had
as one of Harvard's finest I think we're
just like pointing out you know I think
unfortunately for better or worse
they'll always might be a cloud if
you're accused on ways cause campuses
forgets it you know there's no real you
know there's a everything else is it's
performance art Harvard declined to make
anyone available to respond to so no
keys lawsuit saying it does not discuss
pending litigation
the university has now filed a motion to
dismiss the lawsuit calling the lawsuit
meritless and detailing what it says
were three instances of non-consensual
sex the names of the women have not been
made public but Harvard says one of them
claimed to have blacked out at a party
and then awoke to find son okie having
sexual intercourse with her in a
statement Harvard said it is quote
deeply committed to providing a
supportive and inclusive environment for
members of our community and will not
tolerate sexual misconduct including
rape and other forms of sexual assault
unquote up next mystery in the skies who
are what is flying high over the night
skies of Colorado and adjoining states
the FAA and the FBI are investigating
it's a new year with a new mystery about
unidentified flying objects
last year we reported on videos released
by the US Navy that showed unexplained
craft caught on tape by pilots who were
amazed at what they saw now there is a
new set of unexplained objects flying
over the night skies of Colorado and
surrounding states the story started
locally but have been picked up by
national news outlets to drone Michela
cough has been watching large drones fly
over her home for the last week just
after dark several at a time the first
time you actually saw one what did you
think it was odd it honestly it reminded
me of War of the Worlds the sky is lit
up with Christmas lights basically there
is lights and things flying all over
hers is among the hundreds of reports
across several states since December of
large commercial sized drones flying low
at night often in formation it's been
dark for about a half-hour and we are
seeing drones all over the sky they
appear as little twinkling lights
sometimes there's just one but in other
cases we've seen clusters of six or more
all that attention is now led the FBI
and the FAA the Federal Aviation
Administration to join an investigation
with local law enforcement to determine
just what is going on in the skies and
joining us now to learn more is Linda
Moulton Howe the editor of the
earthfiles website which says it's there
to allow experts eyewitnesses and
viewers to share updates on earthly and
astronomical mysteries and Linda as best
you know what's going on right now well
it is only one month ago at the middle
of December and now we're at the middle
of January and there have been hundreds
of reports between Colorado and Nebraska
from people who it almost went
like a move out of Washington in Yuma
counties in Colorado and began expanding
into Nebraska and I have interviewed
several dozen people and the phenomena
keeps going into the category of drones
because so many people say they are
hearing the buzzing sound of what a
drone would be like some people have
seen six to eight foot diameter what
they call flying stop signs that would
be in the drone category but here is the
great puzzle right now as we're speaking
today on January 6th only about a week
and a half or so ago there was a meeting
in brush Colorado and the FBI was there
the FAA was there the army was there
homeland security was there and several
Sheriff's Office's employees and it was
a meeting that the public was told to
stay away most of the media was told
stay away the Denver Post was there and
a couple of TV stations that apparently
knew the sheriff and they have this
meeting and at the end
Phillips County Sheriff put out this
Facebook to the public a task force it's
been organized and we are asking for
your assistance specifically we are
looking for the command vehicle meaning
assuming drones we are looking for a
closed box trailer with antenna or a
large van that does not belong in the
area and they gave the sheriff's office
phone number for people to call and in
48 hours the Phillips County Sheriff's
Office have rescinded everything said
don't call us we are not looking for
this van and nobody today as we are
talking on January 16th of 2020 nobody
knows why was there that rescinding and
why is there nothing but complete
silence from Homeland Security
the FAA basically I from the FBI
from the Army all they've done is say we
can't
confirm malicious intent and the
sheriff's and the people that I've
talked to say whatever is here it keeps
coming back it is repeating it isn't
that 400 feet and it goes up to a
thousand feet and then they say why
wouldn't we the people living in
Colorado and Nebraska be told by
somebody in the government who clearly
must know what is going on because of
the silence and you and I know that when
there is something afoot like a big
story that we haven't even seen yet and
that there are agencies like the FBI and
homeland security and involved and they
remain quietly you and I know something
answers all right we'll lend them out at
the hall thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it very much
up next our shoutout tears of joy from
thousands of people in Memphis thanks to
some great local investigative reporting
and our shout-outs knife for a reporter
in Memphis who with the help of Pro
Publica set up a small nonprofit
journalism operation and then took on
that city's biggest health care provider
in a series of stories that as you will
see had a very surprising outcome
it's the largest healthcare provider in
Memphis and in a promotional video
celebrating its 100-year anniversary
Methodist Bonior hospital makes much of
what it calls a culture of compassion
true to our faith-based mission and
Methodist heritage we have a tradition
of building up our entire community
through a host of local programs from
free cancer screenings to childhood
asthma reduction we are committed to
improving all lives regardless of their
means but a year-long investigation by
journalist Wendy Thomas called the
hospital's compassion into question I
would go to court every Wednesday for
five months watching Methodist in action
documenting an aggressive debt
collection system by the hospital
against those who could not afford to
pay their bills so over a five-year
period Methodist Hospital filed more
than eighty three hundred lawsuits and
when they won a judgment as they always
did they were more successful in their
attempts to garnish wages compared to
the city's other large hospitals and the
people they were filing the lawsuits
against so a lot of those people were
very low-income the benches would be
full of defendants who were really
ill-equipped to deal with this really
savvy legal team that also had you know
good rapport with the judges for Thomas
it was just the latest installment in a
series of reports about her hometown for
a website she founded called MLK 50
standing for 50 years since Martin
Luther King was assassinated in Memphis
this story began kind of with a broader
question which is know why is Memphis so
poor it's the second poorest large city
and the nation come and we wanted to
think about the money that is siphoned
out from these households and so that
God is on the track of debt and
specifically medical debt and the court
records told the story of how Methodists
relentlessly when
after those who could not pay often huge
medical bills
anybody can get sick right any all of us
can relate to that and these people's
mistake if they did make a mistake was
being poor and sick at the same time but
the hospital at first tried to ignore
Thomas and her small nonprofit outlet so
the hospital refused multiple requests
to be interviewed
we of course you know operating by the
no surprises policy you know let them
know what our findings were you know
presented list of questions and they
typically didn't answer most of the
questions and just pretty much Stonewall
us during the whole investigation
tonight a scathing report exposes how a
non-profit Hospital in Memphis is suing
the poor in this city over and over
again but when her story went public it
was the talk of Memphis Methodist filed
more than 83 hundred lawsuits for unpaid
hospital bills during the past five
years so shame as it turns out is a
powerful motivator and after the stories
broke including one about the hospital
suing its own employees who made
sometimes as little as twelve dollars an
hour
outrage was immediate widespread within
five days of the initial story the
hospital suspended all court collection
activities and within another 30 days
they announced major reforms to the
charity care policies making them twice
as generous as they had be had been but
the biggest surprise was yet to come
one by one the people who were being
sued by Methodists discovered that their
debt had been wiped out
in total they ended up erasing at least
eleven point nine million dollars in
unpaid hospital debt that more than
fifty three hundred defendants had so
this is this is good news for for a poor
community like Memphis so for those
fifty three hundred what actually
happened their balance has been marked
as zero with the courts zero it's yeah
it's gone and that must have made you
feel pretty good yeah it did it did I
can remember sitting in the car with the
hospital housekeeper who had been sued
she owed twenty three thousand dollars
that was more than she made the prior
year and I showed her her case satisfied
notice where show said that her balance
was zero and she she was a static yeah
I'll remember that the story has brought
much-needed attention to her MLK fifty
project which has been funded in part by
the nonprofit group
ProPublica in their efforts to promote
good local investigative journalism I
think for journalists particular who are
in low income low wealth communities
like Memphis to think about poverty not
just in terms of who suffers from it but
who profits from it and look for those
who profit and with a nod to what
systems can be changed so you're gonna
keep going yeah absolutely for as long
as long as we can who's next on your hit
list oh I can't tell you that
indeed good work Wendy Thomas that's our
program for tonight thanks for joining
us we'll see you back here next week
you